so continuing our discussion on darkside
war where the first video was a little
slow and that the story was largely
built up from this point going forward
things will actually pick up pretty fast
and last video we had talked about how
lex luger sister had turned on both
himself and superman shooting Lex in the
process and teleporting both men to
apocalypse the planet of Darkseid
picking up with the continuation of this
where some of you had asked how a simple
bullet was able to pierce the armor of
Lex which is designed to withstand blows
from Superman jon's tells us that the
bullet was composed of a metal Lex
doesn't recognize now this is kind of an
offhanded dismissal of the circumstance
but what I want to do here is I want to
talk for a few moments about the armor
of Lex Luthor since this is actually
going to be something that make several
appearances in this story while the wore
suits appearance in DC Comics dates back
to Action Comics number 544 in 1983
within the new 52 this is the third
iteration of Lex's design the first was
actually a giant robot which was
controlled by Lex Luthor and first
showed up and Action Comics number 17
the second was a smaller of a bulkier
suit that appeared in actually comics
issue number 20 leading to the current
suit which appeared in forever evil now
this version is connected to Lex Corp
using his computers I could actually tap
into various satellites allowing Lex
Luthor to access other intelligence
agencies information from around the
world in addition to this it's capable
of energy and electric glass is powered
by solar energy can create force fields
as well as various other abilities that
appear within the context of various
stories as an example in issue number 43
of Justice League and this story will
actually find out but the suit has a
medical system built into it however at
the moment Superman uses his heat vision
to cauterize the wounds of Lex Luthor
after he was shot now this is actually a
pretty big moment for Superman and the
reason why is because this signifies the
attempt of Clark to bridge the gap
between himself and Lex what I mean here
is that like our discussion in the last
video the Superman and Lex have
consistently been enemies because
wherever evil saw Lex Luthor bringing
together the world's villains to save
the world
Superman had to put those issues aside
after recognizing the value in what Lex
brings to the table regarding his
intelligence and resources however Jones
also leads us to determine the other
of this equation and that because both
Superman and lecture on apocalypse we
can make a legitimate argument the Clark
will need the help of Lex to make their
way through the landscape and find a way
back from here we jump to Darkseid
himself now this particular section of
the comic will give us some very
valuable insight into his character as
well as how his servants relate to him
as the ruler of apocalypse Darkseid is
met with the arrival of desaad and
Steppenwolf
who inform him this Superman has arrived
on the planet decide chat for a second
in the pre new 52 continuity desaad was
a new god on new Genesis who had turned
against highfather and joined Darkseid
after being corrupted but because the
line wide reroute of new 52 changed the
history of Darkseid but provides no
history for desaad at this point we can
either assume that his history is either
unknown or the history from before the
new 52 remains the same however
considering that John's is rewriting the
entire story of the new gods under the
new 52 it stands to reason that we
simply just don't know the backstory of
desaad now regarding Steppenwolf in the
pre new 52 continuity his character made
his debut as the uncle of Darkseid and
eventually rose to become his top
general but again in the new 52 like
desaad we don't know the story of
Steppenwolf or how it was that he came
to be one of Darkseid's top two men now
where the idea of Steppenwolf is that he
will kill Superman
using his axe what John's tells us is
that Steppenwolf does not know the
measure of Superman's powers we're seven
wolf has been able to kill other new
gods a darker side makes the case that
Superman isn't the same what John's
means here is that the power of Superman
is to rise or miss Kryptonian physiology
and in many ways Superman is way beyond
the power of the new gods with the
exception of Darkseid himself and
presumably highfather
however the strength variance between
Darkseid and Superman changes based on
the rider and where Jeff lobe and Paul
Jenkins would give us stories where
Superman was stronger within the new 52
Justice League and the Darkseid war
Darkseid himself is stronger than
Superman this combined with the fact
that Darkseid orders the slaves to be
released from the pens even though none
of them could defeat the Man of Steel
tells us that the goal of Darkseid is
not to kill Superman and instead is to
simply keep him preoccupied what we also
learned here is that Darkseid and his
group are aware
the fact that anti-monitor is on earth
and making preparations for war against
Darkseid himself now where this is
John's laying the foundation here for
what will come later I want to take this
time to answer the question of how
Darkseid fits into the conflict as we've
seen it so far
where dark side does not answer
Steppenwolf's question of what they're
fighting for in terms of everything up
to this point all we really know is that
in relation to Darkseid anti-monitor is
a former new god named mobius who had
committed an unknown act in the past and
hidden to make up for it
anti-monitor allied himself with Grail
the daughter of Darkseid for the purpose
of killing Darkseid himself now
transitioning away from this scene and a
scot-free some of you would also express
some confusion as to who marina black is
and how grail fits into the continuity
aside from being an ally of anti-monitor
in the last video we had talked about
how marina black was the top assassin of
temas Kyra and the mother of Rael where
the motives behind this were unclear in
the first issue in this section we learn
that this was done as fulfillment of
marina blacks perception of the role of
Amazon's
what I mean here is that according to
Maria the Amazonians were given their
power for the purpose of working as
Shepherds protecting the world from war
were marina viewed the life of
Amazonians isolation as the group
effectively walking away from their
mission if she were to attempt
insurrection in an effort to return to
the status quo she would likely have
been exiled or executed
however because she intended to maintain
the original mission of the Amazons
despite her knowledge of Darkseid and
the fact that he would one day invade
and enslave the earth she procreated
with him for the purpose of creating a
child whose power would rival both that
of the new gods and the Amazonians
themselves and so after giving birth to
grail and abandoning the mascara marina
began training her daughter in the ways
of combat and instilling in her the
desire to destroy Darkseid
now the extreme view of Marina comes
into play when she makes the case that a
fight between dark side and the
anti-monitor
on earth will result in a high amount of
casualties but for marina
ending the reign of Darkseid is more
important than the lives of those who
will die now this doesn't mean the
marina does not value life instead this
is simply a classic utilitarian argument
what I mean here is that in the realm of
moral philosophy the
utilitarianism makes the case that the
needs of the many are more important
than the needs of the few because
dark-sided highfather rule the
respective lands outside of the
multiverse with Darkseid able to make
conquest against the inhabitants of any
universe in existence the lives of a few
billion on earth are completely
irrelevant in comparison to the lives of
countless others spread across the
multiverse
however because Scott's experience has
made him aware of how powerful Darkseid
is and the fact that he may be immortal
for him there's far too many what-ifs to
sacrifice the lives of billions on a
gamble and so because this puts him at
odds with morena and his fighting skills
are woefully limited in comparison to
her own Scott simply flees for his life
before marina can kill him now jumping
back to earth with the arrival of the
anti-monitor
the story continues a narrative and
Wonder Woman from the previous issue as
the events unfold what she tells us is
that in her experience she's battled
gods and powerful enemies from across
the world and beyond but where the
motives of those beings were clear and
that their hostilities were made
prevalent immediately after they arrival
with the anti-monitor
she has no idea what he's looking for
because he simply just stares at her
battle with Grail another reason for
this seems to be the vast power that
anti-monitor possesses but in the
interest of keeping future events
spoiler-free
I'm actually going to table this portion
of the discussion for now instead where
some tonsure exchange between Wonder
Woman and Grail this section of the
story isn't wildly important except to
provide us with the recognition of
Grails new god Amazonian hybrid
physiology and that it makes her
superior to Wonder Woman and speed and
strength however before she can
intervene the anti-monitor steps into
the battle
now Wonder Woman's reaction here tells
us that the heroes of Prime Earth in the
new 52 have never met or heard of the
anti-monitor which is extremely
important the reason why is because what
Jeff Jones is doing in this story is
completely retconning the origin of the
anti-monitor his role within the DC
universe and the multiverse as well as
how he gained his powers but again with
the story speeding up and pace this
scene is met with the arrival of Metron
who simply appears for an instant offers
a couple words and then teleports away
with the heroes now the conversation
between anti-monitor and grail who
remained at the battles
reveals a couple of things and continues
to fill in the holes the first is that
Grail seems to have waged a personal
vendetta against the Justice League but
at the moment we don't know why the
other is that the pact between
anti-monitor and Grail is rooted in the
fact the Grail promised to lure Darkseid
out and bring him to the anti-monitor
allowing the two to engage in battle now
the next part of the story is extremely
important because at this point
everything will begin to change in
drastic ways when Metron had appeared
and teleported the heroes away he had
moved them and himself to a place called
the rock of eternity as a location that
exists outside of the DC multiverse the
rock of eternity was formerly a base of
operations for Shazam the wizard who
provided Billy Batson with his magical
powers but it also functions as a prison
for the deadliest of magical beings
including the seven demons representing
the seven deadly sins who were the main
foes during the forever evil lead-up
event called Trinity war in addition to
this the history between Hal Jordan and
the new gods comes into play with his
animosity towards Metron what I mean
here is that in last video we had
discussed how the Green Lantern Godhead
story saw highfather leading a campaign
to acquire the various lantern battery
cores and never to gain enough power to
kill Darkseid during the conflict Metron
and made his appearance to chronicle the
events / his role but for how there
seemed to be no differentiation between
Metron and the other new gods that were
Wonder Woman intends to use her lasso as
a way to gain the truth of anti
monitor's origin why intends to wage a
war against Darkseid and how to stop him
the problem that they face is that
Metron himself is not all-knowing
instead the accumulated knowledge of all
things that he's seen and recorded
reside within the möbius chair in
response
Wonder Woman uses the lasso to force
Metron to tell them the truth of how
they can gain answers to their questions
which is revealed to be possible if they
take the chair from him now under normal
circumstances this would be virtually
impossible due to the incredible power
that Metron possesses as a new god but
because he's facing enemies whose power
levels are quite likely on his own this
is not as difficult as it would normally
be
this is coupled with the fact that as we
discussed in my anti-monitor video the
anti-monitor himself had previously
created the chair for his own ends and
handed it down to Metron as such there
existed no information
what would happen if Metron were
separated from the chair but the answer
is revealed when one a woman pulls him
away when this happens the chair
prepares to teleport back to an unknown
location but before it does batman takes
metrans place on the chair now in the
comments section of the last video some
of you had asked me to clarify on what
it was that happened to Batman once you
took metrons place because the chair
holds knowledge of all things the best
way to think about this is that if
knowledge is power the knowledge of all
things that have ever happened flow
through its user now one thing I want to
make clear is that the möbius chair does
not provide answers to why people do the
things they do the möbius chair simply
just chronicles the actions of things
that have happened as an example the
Mobius chair does not Chronicle why a
man would walk into a bank and robbed it
it simply just chronicles the fact that
a man walked into a bank and robbed it
now in this case within the context of
this story because Batman has sat on the
chair
he now has knowledge of everything that
has ever happened in the history of DC
Comics including the various crises DC
has had over the course of their history
and the roots of their various universes
putting this knowledge to the test what
Batman does as he tells us that he knows
the identity of who killed his parents
and that unlike his speculation of the
course involvement during Snyder's
quarter the owl's story that his parents
truly died at the hands of Joe Chill the
other question Batman asks but never
reveals here is the identity of the
Joker now where Batman's reaction tells
us that he does know what I would like
you to do is keep this in the back of
your head because this question will
serve as a major cliffhanger at the end
of the first act of Darkseid war and so
as this portion of the story begins to
come to an end
when the question is asked as to whether
Batman is okay and a survivors
experience he simply replies by stating
that he's now a god
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end and again if
you guys have any questions feel free to
post them down in the comment section
and I'll do my best to answer them
without being said I will catch you guys
later purse